thank you uh yasser wesley this was a
huge victory for you against richie
rapport who was just on fire he won four
games in a row but you stopped him in
this one and this was a crazy game yeah
what are your initial feelings
afterwards well first thanks for having
me christian it's good to see you again
and uh it's good to see your uplifting
spirit and application yes yes so he
played the king's indian as he played
before uh first of all i think this
tournament the level of play
by almost everyone is except bishop it's
very low like i was looking at the games
yesterday there was a lot of one there's
mistakes also i
didn't feel
that i'm 100 percent also i'm not
playing at my hundred percent but when
you play
this maybe is due to the fact that a lot
of
players are coming from a classical
competition to a rapid and blitz
competition that's what my mother says
about this but last year it worked very
well for me in paris because i had
opening preparation all that so it's
it's hard to say which is better with
blitz unwrapped before classical or
classical first
but in any case
when you play the kings indian i mean
give us your uh thoughts about this
crazy game because it's not like you had
the advantage out of the opening then he
had the advantage then you got the
advantage and then some mates came on
the board yeah definitely i want to get
an interesting game i mean if i lose i
lose
but i think i mix up my preparation here
like bishop this usually is good with
the knight black knight on d7
but here wasn't exactly sure what was
happening given that
he himself and vichy were kind of
running away uh creating a big
separation
mostly
was this a must-win game for you in your
mind ah probably but with the way i'm
playing i just wanted to survive
but probably like here for example just
to show you about my bad play like i
played roxy one but in fact i could have
saved the tempo maybe if i play rook a2
and then bishop c1 rook d2 but i said i
played roxy one first and here i did i
didn't know what to do so i played roxy
too
and then bishop c once i basically lost
a tempo for and whole time before
nothing without even realizing it like
um
this tournament i was
missing a lot of opportunities against
lebanon against fabi so it's
if you can't convert
great positions then it's not your
tournament but well sometimes
yeah yeah this is seventh grade
like here i wasn't sure exactly what to
do but
uh i guess i thought my bishop on c1 is
passive so i got activated but somehow
my queen got trapped
and after i played a4 i realized that he
has this g5 h5 idea my queen got trapped
that didn't seem so bad because at least
it doesn't have an attack maybe it's
just a wild game maybe we should play g4
first as the computer says but anyway
here
after rook to b8 i guess rook b2 is a
mistake maybe c5 and i'm okay
but like here everything's falling apart
it's upon up and as you can see the
board is full of black pawns here i
guess it's not so bad huh no no it was
still quite balanced and then it did
seem like you're getting an advantage
mostly because of this uh point right
now d3 seems to be a critical move
nevertheless even after c5 the computer
doesn't really understand exactly what
the assessment is e5 and then you have
to follow it but you see it jumps from
like plus one point five to plus yeah
three doesn't understand much yeah it's
depth
and this was a normal move bishop to b2
right yeah bishop b2 was a mistake i
mean yeah it really is computer
but uh yeah like here i was just hoping
for some tactics i guess 97 was a
mistake too and i don't want to keep you
for very long wesley because you do have
a game coming up in in in five minutes
yeah sure and and i do hear some
applauses from the playing hall so they
might be starting without i don't want
them to start without you
yeah and it's a funny game this was the
critical moment right now you saw rook
h7 and uh a big victory for you you're
playing voitacek what's the strategy
going in the final game yeah just wanna
play fast play solid start to get
invited in the club and try to
attack my point psychologically that's
the best i can do
excellent you have five minutes to get
ready for the final game we'll let you
go good luck in the last game
thank you thank you guys and we're
actually as we are getting ready to
start the final rapid game we're going
to go to a feature let's see what that
is all about
[Music]